remember when J.R Smith went an entire
summer without wearing a shirt well the
reason he stayed shirtless is deeper
than you might know right after the Cavs
came back from being down three to one
to win the NBA Finals they started their
celebration in Las Vegas somewhere
between 3 and 4 am on June 20th 2016 J.R
Smith officially took off his shirt for
the first time but why did JR insist on
going shirtless Smith had been turned
down from clubs for years when he was
younger but after years of rejection at
the door Smith knew he could finally go
anywhere he wanted knowing he wouldn't
be turned away due to his championship
status and justiflox's new VIP status he
decided to go shirtless everywhere he
went he used his tattoos as a T-shirt
and showed up to a Cleveland Browns game
with no tickets in hand and made it
inside his strategy also worked at a
Cleveland Guardians game everybody
shared love Smith went everywhere
shirtless including grocery stores like
Whole Foods he made such a statement
being shirtless that eventually Obama
had to tell him to put on a shirt
foreign